i know let's serve up some news
sunny side up please welcome the man
behind countless blockbusters
oscar golden globe and emmy
award-winning director who needs
no introduction steven spielberg
oh drew face i still care about you i've
always cared about you ever since that
first time
this little blonde hurricane walked into
an audition
in my office and took uh us
by storm and then soon took the entire
world by storm that was you then
and that is you today you know i think
one of the people that mean the most to
me
to be accountable
and a good person and have my you know
what together
is definitely you drew was really
something
but when but her et interview was the
best
because when she walked into the office
she didn't want to talk about the movie
she didn't even
care what the film was about she wanted
to talk to me about her punk band she
was forming
the purple people eaters none of it
really existed but
so we put a song in et
purple people leaders just in order to
please
drew to to make that story kind of have
a full circle
deadline reports that actress simone
ashley
has been cast as the love interest for
anthony bridgerton
played by jonathan bailey now we all
know the new season is going to focus
around their love affair
he is as good as it gets he is riveting
and i think
that she is just beautiful
extraordinary and i want to say
that this is the power of casting when
people take casting risks and they
discover someone it's a very big deal
and i really thank the show for doing
that with simone i'm very excited to see
her well
they did it in season one i wasn't aware
of these actors before and now i'm
obsessed with all of them and i'm
obsessed with her already
i've been pouring through her images she
almost looks different in each photo but
she is
stunning for us we gotta start with some
sex in the city
of course because it's the best show
ever and i still binge it all the time
and we're all patiently waiting for the
reboot to come and save us all and
distract us out of our
woes and we know carrie miranda and
charlotte are back but what about the
rest of the cast
i can't stop thinking about this well
willie garson is back who plays stanford
by the way i've known willie like my
entire life it's hilarious i love him
there's rumors that miranda steve and mr
big
won't be returning wait what yeah will
not that's the rumor that they won't be
returning and i'm
furious what do you want
you didn't need this today right well i
want i i
you take it away rosie i'm set i know
well listen we've all
are still processing the kim cattrall
news that she's not going to be there
right samantha
but now us weekly says actor chris knows
who played big he's finally commented on
this saying
very cryptically quote everything
changes including announcements in the
rags which means
the magazine so maybe it's a fluid
situation
girl we need you now all right i need
them all to show up
enough of this playing coy will they i
want that you're showing up mr big you
understand
steve i know
we're zooming up speaking of this we're
going to space because nasa has captured
their first recording of the sounds of
mars
are you ready everybody hear it i've
been waiting my whole life to hear mars
right yeah you and everyone else i hope
it's out of this world
all right ready listen
silence what that's it that's the first
sounds from mars
that's all we get from ours that's the
big hoopla ross
we traveled all this way to find out
that they get the same cell service on
mars that i got on 57th and 10th
can you hear me now what
let's take a look actually from some of
the red carpet looks over the years i
mean
this is my favorite come on it's sunny
and shared
not perfection right there share i
love when people go for it don't be
afraid take a risk
lupita nuongo in 2014 for 12 years a
slave i think that's when she
established that she has misses dropped
the mic fashion
lady gaga 2019 star is born yeah what
about member back in the julia
roberts in this that she won for steel
magnolias in 1990
wearing something that i think drew's
going to wear on the show next i was
going to say you know i love a tie
and here's angelina jolie in 2011 i
remember
that red carpet i remember i was
watching brad pitt and her pull up in
their car brad got out and walked
around and opened the door and let her
out i was like watching it myself like a
human being they were there and i was
like oh my god
that was one of those moments where you
hold your breath by the way with
angeline it was one of those moments
where you're like oh
oh my god look at that i think that's
the definition of drop
dead gorgeous
[Music]
and today it's the expert an incredible
new platform for design lovers this is
so perfect
for design week so house beautiful
reports that you can now get a
one-on-one consultation with design
gurus like
leanne ford of hgtv's restored by the
ford
bobby burke from queer eye and so many
more
it was co-founded by a designer named
jake arnold who's worked with chrissy
teigen and john legend
here's the gimmick you go on if you can
do
anything from about 150 all the way up
you know far past it but what you do for
150
is you can get a 30 minute consultation
with some of the biggest designers there
are in the world
this is game changing for people who
would probably never have access to that
sort of
level of design they can now get it this
is so huge and you can zoom from your
room
and they can take you through it and
help and guide you the pros
now at 150 bucks a pop what a great way
to start
[Music]
you